- Welcome back to the show.
I'm not David S Pumpkins.
(funky music)
(whip crack)
Today's program will remind
all you kids out there
be careful what you wish for.
You want a loyal best buddy
or a pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow, be my guest.
Or rather, be their victim.
In one corner, we have Chucky,
the tortuous toy trickster
and his opponent,
the limericking,
limestone-laden Leprechaun.
- You may feel some pain.
'Tis a pity I forgot me Novocaine
- These two have transcended the confines
of the horror movie genre
and have permanently cemented themselves
in both the pop culture
lexicon and our nightmares.
Heck, you can even catch them
on every football Saturday and Sunday!
Sports are the ultimate escape
but there is no running from
these tiny Tinseltown terrors.
Here's how we'll determine a winner:
Round one: Box office.
Round two: Tomatometer/audience score.
Round three: Creation story.
And then I'll do a wild card round
that's going to prove this is
the ultimate duel of diminutive devils.
On the line, a fresh pot of gold against
a Toys 'R' Us shopping spree.
Even though I'm fairly certain
Geoffrey the giraffe's doors are closed.
And that gold, let's face it,
it's probably just foil encasing
for subpar milk chocolate.
Hey, I ain't complaining.
Chucky's got his game face ready,
the Leprechaun wore his
best river dancing boots,
So let's get it on.
- It's
showtime.
- You won't beat me,
'cause I'm a leprechaun.
- (bell rings) Round one: Box office.
In past episodes of Vs,
when we talk box office,
it's usually boffo.
Billions of dollars are
tossed around with regularity
and while I don't get to keep any of it,
it's no secret why some other franchises
have remained so popular.
Money talks, but for Child's
Play and Leprechaun movies?
Uh, yeah, let's not start looking
at winter homes in Florida just yet.
- Shit!
- To date, only the first two
of the eight Leprechaun films
have been given a proper
theatrical release.
Remember when he danced
an Irish jig on the moon
or sang about the multiple
definitions of booty
in Leprechaun in the Hood?
Yeah, we enjoyed those on home video.
The franchise has just grossed
$24 million in domestic coin,
making for an average of
12 million per outing.
But even if we give the little leper,
that didn't sound healthy,
a wide release for all eight films?
Chances are he still can't
play with the Chuckster.
- I want respect!
- Child's Play came out in the eighties,
the decade before sentient toys became
our cuddliest Pixar
pals and sliced its way
to an impressive $78
million domestic haul.
Sequels and more profit would follow
until The Curse of Chucky
and then The Cult of Chucky
decided to head directly
to Video Update.
That was the Williamsburg,
Virginia version of Blockbuster.
I still owe them late fees.
- I can't think of a thing to say.
- All told, six of the
eight Child's Play flicks
sold tickets at movie
theaters and they combined
for a $286 million franchise tag.
That makes for a $47.6
million per flick average.
Somehow, that still surpasses
the gross of the recent reboot
featuring Mark Hamill
as the voice of Chucky,
which finished its run at $29 million.
Leprechaun can compete with that number,
but given the Chuckster's head
start in the horror heyday
of the 1980s and his consistent
presence in theaters,
(bell rings) it's an
easy round one victory.
So easy, you might say
it's... child's play?
- What.
- You're right.
I deserve to have a green
goblin curse me forevermore
for making that dad joke.
- Don't fuck with the Chuck!
- (bell rings) Round two:
Tomatometer/audience score.
Okay, Leprechaun, it's your lucky day
because now that we're
done with the finances,
let's talk about your pot of gold.
- Have I mentioned that I want me gold?
- Specifically, how did critics feel
about your extreme methods
in protecting said treasure?
Oh, it's not good.
Here's the bright spot.
The underappreciated
Leprechaun in the Hood
is at 30%!
And Leprechaun Returns,
the most recent entry in the franchise,
has the highest percentage
of all his movies at 44!
We're trending upward,
which is my sugarcoated way
of saying here's the bad news.
Three of the Leprechaun flicks are at 0%.
- Zero
point
zero.
- The one that started
it all and introduced us
to Jennifer Aniston
pre-Rachel cut is just at 23%.
So, this all makes for an
average film score of 16.6%.
But, hey, these are horror movies,
they never sit well with
the critics, said the person
who doesn't have a
teleprompter in front of them.
I know because Child's Play
movies do pretty darn well.
Half of the films in the
franchise, get this, are fresh.
That's four movies about a murderous doll
that critics said, yep, that's cinema.
- What are you looking at?
- 71% is the score for the original flick
that started it all.
Then Curse of Chucky broke the curse
of direct to Red Box and earned a 76%.
Cult of Chucky then set
the all-time high at 79%.
The most recent reboot
is also fresh at 63%,
so it's been a nice turnaround for Chuck.
His lowest movie is Child's Play 3 at 29%,
but overall he's still on
the outskirts of Fresh Town
with a 55% average for eight movies.
This doll can kill you with
a knife or the kind words
movie reviewers have
given him over the years.
- You fucking with me?
- Okay, okay, but that audience score
has got to favor the Leprechaun, right?
I mean, he was referenced
in Wayne's World.
- Garth, I'm the Leprechaun!
- Cool it, okay.
- Unfortunately, it appears
most of the audience?
Sided with Garth.
Leprechaun does better in this frame
but his 30% average is still dwarfed,
oh, sorry about that,
(spooky flute music)
by Chucky's 53% average.
Curse of Chucky is the doll's peak
on the audience side of things at 76%
and the closest the
Irish troll gets to fresh
is a respectable 48%
for Leprechaun Returns.
Which, if you're keeping
score at home, is 2% higher
than Constantine, staring Keanu Reeves!
Sorry, Jacqueline Coley,
maybe Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong?
Enjoy our podcast wherever
you listen to stuff.
- Fine!
All right, already.
- (bell rings) Child's Play
takes round two and it appears
the Leprechaun has just
about reached the end
of his rainbow.
- I am Chucky,
the killer doll!
And I dig it!
(thunder clap)
- (bell rings) Round
three: Creation story.
The Fighting Irish football team has been
mythologically great
at late game comebacks.
And if Leprechaun wants to
prove he's the next Joe Montana,
it'll take one convincing tall tale.
Ah, I said tall.
My bad.
- About three-foot-six.
- [woman] Three-foot-six?
- Yeah, but I make up
for it in other areas.
- Creator Mark Davis wanted
to make a horror movie.
You know what inspired him?
Yep.
Lucky Charms.
He saw an ad for the cereal,
which I ate not two hours ago,
and the rest is cinematic history.
- Fuck you, Lucky Charms.
- So, while the actual genesis
of the movie franchise itself
is giggle-worthy, the war of
the Leprechaun is dead serious.
Each movie spins a slightly
different version of the tale.
Our villain can be anywhere
from 600 to 2000 years old.
Originally, he got his pot of gold stolen,
chased it across the
Atlantic to North Dakota,
where he got boxed there
for 10 years before escaping
in go-karts.
(engine rattle)
- Ring around the rosie!
- Since then, his mission
has varied from revenge,
like in Back to the
Hood, to finding a bride,
as seen in part two.
He went to Los Angeles to
achieve the bride goal.
Good luck, pal, the line
starts right behind me.
- Something new, something old,
let's be together
on Leprechaun's gold.
- Based on the war in Origins,
he may actually be a God!
Or at least a being with
supernatural powers,
ones that keep him in statue
form until a medallion
is removed from the adorable
lawn ornament exterior.
It's tough to keep up
with all that creativity
but Chucky doesn't care.
His story has remained
comparatively steadfast
but no less compelling.
The Lakeshore Strangler
managed to transfer his soul
into a Good Guy doll by way
of voodoo just before he died.
The Strangler's name?
Charles Lee Ray.
Why?
Because of course it is.
Never trust someone who
goes by three names,
they could be a killer.
- I'm not ashamed to be a killer.
I'm proud of it.
It's not an addiction, it is a choice
and it is not something that you should
have to hide in the closet.
- Even the good ones!
Keegan-Michael Key murders us
all with his delightful comedy
and David Lee Roth slaughters
rock arenas around the globe.
I don't even trust F. Scott Fitzgerald.
He killed Jay Gatsby, right?
As for the old sport, Chucky, the magic
isn't just in his creation,
it's in his multiple resurrections.
Yeah, he's been brought back to life
by electrical malfunctions, stitching,
some of his blood falling into a vat
used to make more Good Guy dolls.
That's a bad day at the plant.
And in the most recent version,
AI was the cause of him
coming back to life.
Don Mancini is the genius
behind Child's Play.
He wrote seven of the scripts
and directed three films
in the franchise.
And while the origin story
of his beloved evil creation
gets points for consistency,
the greatness of Leprechaun
lies in the fact that
none of us really know how we
got here in the first place.
And thus, how the hell do we
game plan in case he returns?
Both evil entities have proven
they'll never really die
but if we're going off of who had
the most interesting birth?
I have to apologize to
everyone in New Orleans,
particularly that one woman
that worked in the store in the
French Quarter that I'm
pretty sure cursed me
after a comedy show.
Voodoo is powerful and I respect it.
But what are all the kids trying to take?
Me Lucky Charms!
- (bell rings) Leprechaun wins round three
and is back in the game.
- Oh, so you know the Lep
is the real OG.
- (bell rings) And now it's time for
the Wild card round: Iconic moments.
This is where the luck of
the Irish could come up huge.
Even for a monster that needs an EpiPen
if he's around four leaf clovers.
Say what you want about
lackluster box office
or Rotten Tomato meters,
both Chucky and the Leprechaun
are firmly entrenched
in the cultural zeitgeist for a reason.
They've given us plenty of
highlights over the years.
- Hello, Andy.
- Going back to the first Child's Play,
Chuck has always had a
flare for the dramatic.
He used a voodoo doll to killed Dr. Death
and as impressive as a start as that is,
what I consider to be
the most iconic would be
how he met his bride-to-be.
It's the classic story
we were all told as kids.
Grandpa dumped a TV into
the bathroom to off Grandma.
The movie playing on said
television at the time?
Bride of Frankenstein.
It works on so many levels.
- Hey, Raggedy Anne, you
looked in the mirror lately?
Now's not the time to get picky.
- Chucky has wreaked havoc
on folks with his go-to
weapon of choice, a butcher knife.
- So, were you born with that knife
super glued onto your hand or what?
- But occasionally, he goes to
the bench and calls in, say,
an ax in Curse of Chucky,
a yard stick in Child's Play 2
or how about Child's Play 3,
when he throws the proverbial kitchen sink
at this poor fella.
Is that a golf club and
a yo-yo?
Major points for creativity, buddy.
- Nothing like a strangulation
to get the circulation going.
- His counterpart is
also a gifted improviser,
as the leprechaun has utilized
everything from a pogo stick
to a lawnmower blade to make
memorable deaths in his movies.
A personal favorite is when
Leprechaun, in outer space,
sneaks his essence into
a guy's body via pee,
then transfers himself into another person
when those two morons
decided to do the nasty.
- Holy shit!
(Chucky laughs)
And they call me sick?
- Sadly, this is not the first time
I've had to remind folks
watching this show,
do not have sex in space.
Why is this so difficult?
It should be like day one of NASA school.
Thank you, class, see you tomorrow
when we'll talk about how
to not pee on a tiny corpse.
It's a dead body, not snow.
- Let that be a lesson to you, lad.
- Besides that flick being my favorite one
to bring up at dinner parties,
it also features a light saber kill.
Fitting, because who plays the Leprechaun?
Yep, Star Wars veteran Warwick Davis.
He borrowed that laser sword
from the latest voice of
Chucky and never gave it back.
But my favorite gruesome kill
in any of the Leprechaun films
has got to be in the 0% fresh part three,
when a poor woman combusts
in front of our eyes.
Or in part two, when a guy gets
a pot of gold in his tummy.
Or in Back in the Hood,
when some poor sat meets
his demise at the hands of
a bong-wielding Leprechaun.
Look out, Californians, that
could happen to any one of us.
(Leprechaun coughs and laughs)
- Each fella has a wicked
smart sense of humor.
Chucky loves a good
laugh and the Leprechaun
kicked off his franchise
featuring a wheelchair chase scene
that rivals the Rascal
scooter chase from Seinfeld.
Both these are horror movies,
so what's the truly most
terrifying scene from each set?
For Chucky, it's when we all find out
he ain't running on batteries.
It's in the very first film
and when that knowledge meets
the fact that he survived
a gunshot?
Look out.
- Sometimes I scare myself.
- This rampaging Ruxpin is going to be
running with the devil long after
the Energizer Bunny peters out.
For good old greeny, I'm going to go
with more recent offerings.
It's a toss-up between Leprechaun Returns,
when he pops out a poor Ozzy's stomach,
or in Origins, when he shows
the world, he may be old
but he still plays video games.
Fatality.
Chucky is great and has
given us a closet full
of memories to cherish
but the lengths the
Leprechaun has gone for us
cannot be denied.
The trip from Ireland is
worthy of consideration
but then to go to the hood
twice and outer space?
Again, the Leprechaun went to outer space.
And flattened a guy.
It's so gnarly.
(bell rings) Leprechaun gets
the win in the wildcard round
and we got us a tied ball game.
- I'm the man of green come to do no good,
Lep in the hood come to do no good.
- Yes, it's been a back
and forth slug fest
that has resulted in a tie.
But did you tune in to see a draw?
What, do you think Chucky and Leprechaun
are just gonna shake hands, buddy up
and go live with Annabel
in the next great sitcom?
Devil Babies is filmed before
a live studio audience.
(upbeat music)
♪ It's a rare condition ♪
- Uh, Ubu ain't gonna sit for that
and I know you folks want a winner.
So, here we go with one final question:
Who'd win in a fight?
Leprechaun is much older,
but that could prove wiser
against his younger opponent.
Chucky does have just as many
movies under his overalls
and although he doesn't have
the frequent flyer miles
of his elder, he does have voodoo.
That could counteract Leprechaun's magic.
And if Chucky gets his hands on the gold,
it might further reduce
Leprechaun's powers.
Both fellas tend to have
a weakness for the ladies
but it's my estimation that
Leprechaun has more holes
in his game than Chuck.
Four leaf clover, iron,
eating Count Chocula
instead of Lucky Charms.
Chucky has assets that work
against the Leprechaun.
And he's got a whole cult
and a loving bride that
could jump into the fracas.
Binging the Leprechaun
movies is an Ellis family
St. Patrick's Day tradition.
But if he ever runs across Chucky,
all the grain in the world
won't save him from getting pinched.
(bell rings) No shame in
losing to a doll, Leprechaun,
especially one voiced by Brad Dourif.
- You know?
I love being me.
- And I love my job.
- I'm fucking infamous.
- Chucky wins but that's
just according to my book.
And I can barely read.
Now it's your turn, my lovely viewers.
Comment below, vote with your pick.
Is it the box office king Chucky
or the magical mystery of the Leprechaun?
I can't wait to have somebody
else read me your take
and I'll leave you with
what your senior quote
should have been.
I'll take it from you, homie, you'll see,
'cause you know the
Leprechaun is the real OG.
(upbeat music)